thank you for joining us today for the
third and final webinar in our machine
learning series deep learning for audio
and natural language processing we're
happy to welcome today's presenters
Carlo Giacometti and Jerome Lourdes or
from algorithms R&D and advanced
research teams Carlo will be presenting
on some of the newest audio
functionality in the Wolfram language
and Jerome will be speaking about
natural language processing with neural
networks during the webinar we'll share
many online resources and links with you
my name is Cassie Hinkle project manager
with Wolfram research
I am your online host for this machine
learning series I am joined by several
of my Wolfram colleagues behind the
scenes to respond to your typed
questions during the webinar and help
point you to the resources you need feel
free to submit your questions using the
control panel on the right side of your
screen you can resize the windows to
customize your webinar experience we
have had good success with Firefox and
Chrome browsers so if you do experience
any problems with the screen sharing or
audio stream you might want to try
logging out and logging back in with a
different browser today's webinar is a
great opportunity for you to learn more
about deep learning approaches for audio
and natural language processing links to
the presentation notebooks and a
recording of today's session will be
sent to you in a few days so you can
continue to build on your understanding
and work with the examples before
passing the microphone to Carlo I'm
going to share a quick poll question
asking about your motivation for
participating in today's webinar all
right so it looks like like I said a
good majority of everyone is interested
in both of the areas with some
interested just in the audio and some
just in the natural language processing
so I'm glad to see not very many people
aren't interested in either so let's do
one more poll before passing this over
to to Carlo
I want to see what deep learning
frameworks you guys have already you
used or know about and so go ahead and
answer when you see the poll okay so it
seems fairly unsurprisingly that the
majority of you guys is the existence of
law but with a non negligible portion of
you
being familiar with fighters and chaos
and a bit of you with glue an MX net as
well okay so I will go ahead and stop my
presentation so my name is Carmel
Giacometti's I am Ackerman developer for
optimization today we'll talk about
neural network applications for audio
processing um the main topics there were
touch upon today will be first of all a
feature extraction business how to feed
an only signal to neural network and
then I will show examples of
convolutional networks recurrent
networks for audio classification
problems then I will show an example of
a sequence to sequence Network and in
closing our give a quick overview of
what current would have for audio
processing in the bottom neural net
repository so first of all the main
question is what do we want to do with
an audio signal what information do we
want to extract the basic one that we
can look for the low-level descriptives
very basic things like your mass
amplitude the spectral flatness the
loudness all quantities that can be
computed very easily from the sample
values of the recording we might want to
do some classification of audio signals
so you have a recording as an input and
you want the probability of the
recording belonging to a specific class
then there is the huge field of speech
analysis and of curves there are a lot
of subcategories here
just listed a few here you can have
voice activity detection you can have
speaker separations because verification
speaker recognition you can have
transcription which is like the most
common I guess tasks given a recording
you want to transcribe what was said you
could have event detection you want to
know what events happen are exactly what
times and there's the whole field of the
music information retrieval when you
have a recording and you want high-level
information about the music that was
played in that recording for example
transcribers curve or find out what key
that recording was in or what curves
were played etcetera etcetera until a
few years ago all these tasks were
accomplished using very handcrafted and
fine-tuned features and extremely
complex statistical tools now as you all
know in the recent years
machine learning neural networks had a
huge impact on many fields including
audio analysis so the paradigm has
shifted from crafting these features and
tools towards leveraging massive amounts
of computational power and annotated
data so instead of crafting all these
features and tools you just grab a huge
amount of data throw it in an
appropriate architecture and let the
network train and most of the
state-of-the-art results for example in
speech analysis in event detection and
music information retrieval all of the
state-of-the-art result currently they
are now leveraging in the neural
networks our advanced machine learning
techniques so first of all we to know
what and all the object is in the ratham
language it's very simple you can see
this isn't on the object I will play for
you now
in its essence it is just a sequence of
values that are played at specific time
we can plot these values using some
native function of the bottom language
so what is the main characteristic of
this this is the variable length
sequence of values that can be extremely
long this is about two seconds of
recording and we have already almost
100,000 samples clearly this is a kind
of an unfriendly firm for a neural
network so how do we feed this
information into a network I guess you
guys some of you at least have been at
the other webinars in this series so you
are familiar with the concept of net
encoder these are constructs in the
Wolfram language that massage the input
data into a format that a neural network
is separate and this massaging happens
in a very optimized and parallelized way
so you can have collections of files in
your hard drive you and have extensive
files huge files huge collections and
this will make it fast and efficient in
version 11 3 we introduced the net
encoders for audio objects so we have a
family of these audio nut encoders there
are some tights in this family that are
common to all the net encoders
these are pre-processing steps that
happen before the feature extraction so
first of all we want our signal to be a
single channel so all the channels are
averaged to a single one we might want
to have some form of normalization of
the signal so you want lioness to be a
specific value of the error message need
to be a specific value you might want to
extract a specific part of the signal so
you might want to do either timing or
padding the most poor possibly the most
important of all you want to resample
all of your collection to a common
sample right because you might have a
collection of recordings and there's
nothing that guarantees you that they
will have all the same separate
and the possible inputs for these
ordinate encoders or the objects of
course which is what you have seen here
but they can also be five objects so you
could have as I said a huge collection
of recordings on your hard drive and
these net encoders will allow you to try
a neural network based on that
collection without having to import all
that data into Mathematica before here
the importing is done on the fly during
the training so I said these net
encoders provide some form of feature
extraction
what kind so the most basic feature is
just the way from the collection of
samples as I showed before so here I am
extracting the audio data as I showed in
the previous slide as you can see is a
fairly long sequence this first number
is the number of channels and again you
can see the plot and this this bit of
code essentially is what the audio net
encoding does as I said it already has
all of the parameters that are common to
all of the all of the encoders for
sample write normalization the target
and the target length so as I said the
problem says that the length can be very
high here I am computing the length of
all the example data collection that we
have in the mathematical layout and here
I'm plotting a histogram of it is hugely
valuable and it can be extremely high so
one way of compacting this data and to a
more a format that's more common in in
neural network application there is
partitioning this data here I'm
petitioning with a certain window size
with a specified offset and as you can
see this becomes a two-dimensional
matrix which is essentially what in
images the first dimension is still
valuable that depends on the duration of
the signal we will not get around that
the other problem with this is that the
signal in a petition will vary
dramatically on where the beginning of
that partition is even a change of 1% in
the starting position of the application
you can have a huge effect on the shape
of the signal essentially what I'm
trying to say is that the signal in
every partition is extremely dependent
on the phase now if we want to minimize
the sensitivity phase and maybe we want
to have a representation that allows us
to investigate both the time domain and
the frequency domain
we can apply a Fourier transform to each
of these partitions and this is what I'm
here applying Fourier to each of the
partitions and this is in essence what
the audio SD FD which stands for short
time Fourier transform does you see here
we under two parameters the window size
and the offset which have the
characteristic elements of the
partitioning operation now this the size
of the of the output of this encoder is
kind of problem a slightly problematic
at least it has complex entries there
the forget announced firm has o there is
also a Fourier transform is usually
complex values one operation that is
usually done to discover this phase
information is taking the absolute value
of that this is the magnitude spectrum
and we also can note that half of a
Fourier transform of the real signal is
redundant so we can it is just symmetric
so what we can do is discard the somatic
path and take the absolute value of it
and here we'll plot this spectrogram
here so you have what's there this is
the time and this is the frequency so
this is a representation that appeals to
us because this is
we here in general we can recognize the
evolution as a function of time but we
recognize sounds there are different
frequencies this is what the audio
spectrogram nothing kind of does now the
next step that we can take in our
feature extra extraction is to mimic the
frequency perception that we have as
humans our frequency perception is
definitely nonlinear so one common
description of this non-linearity is the
mel scale this if you see this this is a
representation of this mapping between
heads and Mel scale it starts with a but
then it it becomes one more look at me
so what we can do is filtering the
spectrogram with these with bandpass
filters that are spaced linearly
according to the mel scale so this is
what I'm computing here I am computing a
filter Bank of melters and I'm plotting
the first few of them as you can see the
spacing between them is nonlinear so
let's apply this filter Bank to the
spectrogram there we go and you can
notice that time dimension is of course
the same but the frequency dimension has
dramatically shot this is controlled by
the number of filters that we used so
this is a plot of the result same kind
of thing as the spectrogram you have a
time axis which actually the legends are
worst
sorry about that the time axis and the
frequency axis and the frequency axis is
much more akin to what we are used to in
terms of frequency perception and this
is what the audio spectrogram nothink
all of us and here we added some
parameters for these frequency filters
so minimum
maximum frequency and number of filters
the last step that we can take if we
want to reduce the dimensionality of the
computer features further is to compute
the mall frequency sub stock
coefficients so a common strategy is to
apply the discrete cosine transform to
the loggerhead of the mouse bacterium in
in the bottom language that is
accomplished using the food ethnicity
and what is usually done is only the
lower other components are kept and all
the higher-order components of this
carbonyl and a usual cutoff is the
component number 15 it's very arbitrary
and many different variations of
necessaries but this is kind of a fairly
common approach this is a plot of their
of the result again with time and
coefficient number axis and we can
accomplish this using the audio M FCC
net encoder and the only parameter that
has been added and this one is the
number of coefficients so we started
with a sequence of about 80,000 elements
and we managed to reduce it to a matrix
of 154 by 13 so we accomplished firmly
successfully a fairly dramatic dimension
reduction of our signal hopefully while
keeping a lot of the original
information so the other important thing
to mention about this these audio net
encoders is the efficiency that comes
with them this the leverages
polarization and out of curvature
extractor so you could compute for
example M FCC features already in
Mathematica version 11 if I am not
mistaken but even by using tricks like
using parallel map the timings for in
this case I am considering a collection
of 5000 short audio signal
they said the timings where is low
enough that it would not be feasible to
do this operation online while training
a network and you can see the
significant performance gains that we
have using the new net encoders and in a
very similar way the same thing happens
for an out of collection of audio
recordings so now let's move on to some
practical examples of neural networks
and in the Wolfram language for audio
processing in most of the examples that
I will show today I will use this with a
source object the spoken digit commands
this is a subset that we selected from
the speech commands data set that was
released by Google so you if you
attended the last few webinars you are
commonly familiar with the mm nest image
recognition database there's a
collection of hundred and digits and a
lot of the basic example and benchmarks
in image in image processing with neural
networks I've done onto this and this
database deficit so we wanted to have an
analogous spoken amnesty data set into
the reserve system so we could retrieve
all the data easily within the Wolfram
language without having to manually
download some bigdhaas that hosted
somewhere external so this way we have
access easily easy access to this mmm
you could call it a toy data set but it
is a good example a good testing ground
for audio processing with neural
networks so will download here the
training data and the testing data and I
will
a sample of three elements of the
testing of the training data well
hopefully okay this doesn't go overly
well let's try it again sorry
alright connection evidently is not
great okay here we go so this is a
sample you can see we have three fields
we have an input field a speaker ID and
the expected output which is a digit
between zero and nine I'm not sure if
you could hear this possibly not anyways
it's just as a recording of less than
one second of this specific digit so one
important thing to note is that the
speakers in the training data I mean the
test data are different so you train
your network on a set of speakers and
then you want to test your network on a
different set of speakers so you make
sure that the network hasn't learned
about the specific speakers but just the
output and it is generalizable to
different speakers that were not in the
training phase and you can check this by
working at the intersection of the
speaker IDs in the training and in the
testing data as I said the possible
output values are all digits from 0 to 9
very conveniently and the length of all
the input signals is between 0.5 and 1
seconds and the majority of the signals
is around one second
[Music]
let's see if this displays here we go as
I said the majority of the samples is
around one second long this is a
convenient thing to keep in mind so as I
said convolutional neural networks I
said we are playing with a spoken
version of them nest so why not start
with add the network that is usually
used in the amnesty benchmark the famous
Leonard that I'm sure you have seen in
one occasion of another uhm so Leonard
expects a fixed size input specifically
it expects 28 by 28 pixel images so what
we can do is set all the parameters for
our audience to produce samples to
produce fish chefs that are 28 by 28
elements so first of all let's grab the
net model that corresponds to the net
trained on amnesty data and we want the
uninitialized evaluation net this means
that it is just the network definition
this desert doesn't contain any pre
trained weights or biases mainly because
all of the ways of biases and biases
that are that would be trained on
amnesty da they would be fairly useless
on the data that we have which is
completely different the only common
thing is the fact that it will be a 28
by 28 matrix but the content of this 28
by 28 matrix will be extremely different
so we will use an audio MF CC encoder
this choice is so we can get a fairly
small feature in terms of dimensions
hopefully while keeping most of the
information of the input signal and we
said we want
at 28 by 28 matrix so we set target line
to 28 and the combination of window size
and offset will guarantee that this
target length will be one second and the
other axis will be also fixed 28 number
of coefficients well determine that
dimension of the other axis as you can
see the output the net weather
conveniently tells us the size of the
output this will be a matrix that will
be 28 by 28 so Lynette we can look at
this here expects an image as an input
now this gets converted to a three
tensor where you have height and width
of the image and number of channels so
we are missing this number of channels
so what we can do is convert this 28 by
28 matrix to a three tensor by
prepending to the network replicate
layer so this will convert our 28 by 28
input into a 1 by 28 by 28 matrix which
is what Leonard expects now using net
apply spark we we can attach the encoder
we defined up here and the appropriate
net decoder to the line that we defined
so here we go we have audio MFC input
and a class net decoder on the output so
we want to speed up the convergence and
we want to prevent overfitting so what
we can do is replace every convolution
layer with a combination of itself and
abashed normalization layer you can test
this yourself you can train the network
with and without this partial
normalization you'll see the difference
is quite dramatic this provides some
kind of normalization between the non
linearity speeds up the timing
significant
and we can visualize the summary graphic
of this network so it is a fairly
straightforward network it's just a
linear chain with two convolution blocks
and then classification stack that's
composed of two linear layers and their
nonlinearities so we want to turn this I
will let net rain worry about all the
hacker parameters but ursa is let me
write etc etc so you can see the network
here I'm training data
I want a net result object is an output
and here I define a validation set as a
5% of the training data I will run this
quickly I might stop the training just
so we want waste time but you can see
this will take less than 10 minutes to
Train and I guess now it is slower than
usual on my machine mainly because I'm
sharing but and my machine is fairly old
as well so it isn't extremely
thanks to the audio net encoders the
training process is extremely fast I
imported in the notebook at written
version of the net OS trained with
exactly the same code I'm not doing any
tricks here we can use classifier
measurements on the network to measure
the performance and this hopefully will
run quickly here we go
by using a standard attic architecture
that's used in image processing without
putting almost any effort to adapting it
to audio we get a 90% accuracy it's not
bad so now let's move on to something
more audio specific I want to look at
recurrent networks so what we'll do is
we want to embrace the variable length
nature of the problem we want to specify
in the encoder time target length goes
to all so here we go that's the only
difference between this and coordinate
and the one that we used previously this
case the output will be a matrix where
the first dimension will be varying and
the second one will be 28 which is
controlled by this number of
coefficients as we said we will use a
recurrent network architecture it will
be based on the Galle recurrent layer
which is very one of the many variations
of a recurrent layer the idea is that
this layer will return its state every
time step but it's time step will have
the state information that comes from
the previous time step so what happens
is at any time T the network will have
some information about all of the
previous entries so we are we don't want
though a variable length output we want
a classification so we have something of
value blank that goes in but we want a
single value as an output so what we can
do is using sequence last layer to
extract the last state of the sequence
of tastes of the gated recurrent layer
and once we have this last state we can
just use a couple of fully connected
layers to do the classification
this is the architecture as I said it's
very simple it's a couple of gated
recurrent layers so you have a sequence
of states here this n by 64 is a
sequence of states of the galerkin layer
this sequence last layer extracts the
last of the sequence and then we're just
planning to classify this vector of 64
elements into one of our ten classes
also here the training is very quick
also here I will not worry about hyper
parameters as you can see the speed is
very comparable to the CNN architecture
our stop again because we are kind of
pressed for time you can see here and
the previous output I had a sketch of
the lost evolution the evolution plot
and again I am importing a network a
pre-trained network that was trained
using these exact functions and we can
measure as we did before the performance
of this recurrent Network on the testing
data and here we get 94% of accuracy so
quite a good result now we can have an
interlude here we have we have a couple
of pre train network so what can we do
with this predator network sure you give
it an input and it outputs a number now
is there something more advanced or more
interesting that we can do with that so
one option is to take for example the
other name network and chop off the last
two classification layers the last yes
the two the last classification layer so
what happens here is with a valuable
length input which is our audio signal
the output here is a single vector of
size 64
and hopefully the single vector of size
64 will have a lot of semantic
information and about the input signal
so what I am doing here is I am doing a
feature space plot by using this chop
Network as a feature extractor so they
reach all your signal the X target
feature will be a single vector of 64
elements and let's see this computes
fairly quickly hopefully so let's take a
bit longer than when it is not sharing
hopefully we'll get it now
here we go and as you can see just by
computing the features with this chop
Network we can see a very dramatic
clustering of data that belongs
different classes so yeah all of the
trees are bunched here or of the AIDS or
the AIDS are bunched here etc etcetera
you can see there are some miss miss
classifications but still so this is a
common paradigm you try in a network on
a big classification problem and then
you chop chop off the last few layers
that do the classification work and use
the chop network as a feature extractor
now we can also test this dye network on
a live signal so I will create a stream
from my microphone and I will use the
current audio functionality which is not
yet at least
it will be released in the next version
and keep in mind this is still very
experimental so what I will be doing is
get the data directly from my mate
microphone and feed it in real time to
the network and let's see if this work
and hopefully so it only cares another
thing you can do if you want to test it
on one on a real signal you can say you
kind of occurred from your microphone
let's see if this works
seven
here we get our nice curving and we can
feed the recording that we just did okay
maybe it does and let's see okay
actually worked
excellent now on to a slightly more
complicated example we have done second
classification but or if we want to try
transduction we want a sequence of in
this case and FCC features to go into
the network and another sequence of a
potentially different lengths of the
characters to come out of the network so
the first step is to add string labels
to our data so the labels will be the
string corresponding digit this will not
be a general speech recognition at the
network because it will be exposed only
to ten words in total so savvy both
speech recognition but possibly a good
example of the general process that is
necessary so actor doesn't in general
change the length of the input the
output like will be the same as the
input length now what we can do to
collapse this output line to something
shortened like a list of characters we
could use the CDC beam search net the
coder so the net decoder with an input
of M steps and M different classes
because I will expect an input of
dimensions and M plus 1 where this plus
1 is the special blank character that is
useful in the decoding process and given
this information that the coder will
find the most likely sequence of all
states by collapsing all of the ones
that are not separated by a blanks
so again here we have the same net
encoder
and in this case we will use the CDC
beam search nap decoder the architecture
will be kind of similar to what we
previously used instead of a simple
gated recurrent player will have a
bidirectional galerkin layer which means
that you applied the layer on a sequence
and at the same time you apply the same
layer on the reverse sequence and you
reverse the output so every time T this
this layer will have information about
both the future and the past so this
will be again the graph that we're
considering the training will just need
to have a loss function specified in
this case the CTC loss layer and the
same is exactly the same as the other
training processes I like again I will
not run it now I will import the network
that has been trained with this code so
what do we get out of this network this
is the testing random choice of the
testing data so you have the input the
speaker ID the output as number and the
output as a string let's look at how the
network behaves as you can see it
outputs a list of characters now we can
work at the output of the network before
the CPC decoding so the probability at
each time step to each of the characters
so this is time and this is the
character the first row here is the
blank card and you can see this goes oh
and E and we can show this corresponding
on top of a spectrum you can see this is
temporarily temporarily aligned onto the
spectrogram so this is where the one
atoms has said and as you can see there
the characters
a time aligned so we can walk this
network definitely can make spelling
mistakes so what we can we can look at
these going mistakes by applying this
network on all of the testing data and
join the result and do a big work cloud
of it
so this is all of the examples that were
classified as zero as you can see that
according works well all of the examples
that were belong to the one class and as
you can see there are some miss
classification there is some spelling
mistakes etc etc we can fix a lot of
these small spelling mistakes just by
using a nearest function so if you have
something like six off it gets corrected
by six now we want to use classifier
measurements and to classify these
string results into specific classes so
this is what we're building here and
let's see how it works you can see the
input is a list of characters and the
output is an association where the
values are the probabilities of the
input belonging to that specific class
so the policy for all digits zero except
for six where it is one and we can test
this we can measure this performance of
the network this way using classifier
measurements and the results are quite
good as you can see we get nine more
than 95% accuracy on the testing data
set but I think the more than the
accuracy here the interesting thing is
to look at the output of a recurrent
network and how then the decoder
converts this
into a small list of characters the last
thing i wanted to quickly talk about is
the vote from neural net repository you
probably have been introduced to it
already
the majority of networks that are in
that deal with images and text but we
are planning to add more audio related
models currently we only have to I guess
one and a half one will be released
within this week the first one and the
most interesting one I guess is Baidu
search deep speech - and this is a
fairly complicated network there is kind
of some complex stuff going on in this
net by directional operator this is
trained on a automatic speech
recognition task and the decoding uses a
CDC beam search which is what we have
looked at before so I will show you how
to well how to use it is very
straightforward so this is an example of
an input right then perfect yeah I'm
what this person said and is just easy
to apply the deep speech Network on to
the audio object it is a fairly resource
intensive network but it is very
impressive in terms of results you can
see it does have some spelling mistakes
but if you really want to use this and
have very active accurate results you
could potentially join this and one of
the language models that are also
present in that repository you can for
example work at the top the coatings
that the ctc decoder proposes for this
input another one is a pitch detection
network which will be released so it
should already be accessible like this
it will be released fully in next week
or so
it's a family straight forward Network
it's a chain of sick
involution all stacks and the output
represents the probability of the pitch
being one in one of the 360 frequency
classes that have normal in every space
now the interesting thing is that unlike
all of the networks that I shown before
this doesn't doesn't get applied to a
time frequency feature like spectrum or
MFC see this gets applied directly on
the time domain data so it partitions
the data in in partitions of about 1,000
elements that will get applied to each
of these partitions and you can define a
hidden markov causes to decode the
output of this network and I will show
you an example with this cello sound
that's just a single note I chose it
okay
sorry about that
there is some issue evidently with the
[Music]
version of Mathematica that I have
anyways once this net evaluation
function is defined the decoding of this
is is immediate it's just a matter of
calling this function onto it and with
this my presentation is finished
I will pass the microphone to zero and
we will have a question and answer
session after Joan's presentation thank
you very much
no sink you come up okay so now we are
going to talk about processing text data
so there is a point in common with the
audio is that we are talking about this
processing sequences with neural
networks so I will first introduce what
is special about text data with respect
to all your images and then I will
present four types of techniques to
process text so further embeddings which
is present in all the processing so we
will see what it is then I will show an
example of classification of text an
example of language models and finally
an example of sequence to sequence
models that are used to do for example
translation so first what is special alt
text so it's that we have a variable
length sequences of tokens so what we
call by tokens is a symbol so here
language is our big sequences of symbols
and in the world of neural networks you
can decide it to model this symbol at
several levels
so these symbols can be characters words
and punctuation marks or even multi
watch groups of words or sub words it
depends on the task what is one of the
most relevant and also when we we talk
about text the scope can be different so
we can we can process a word or sentence
or paragraph an article a book it really
depends to illustrate the token thing I
will show how we can we can tokenize
that is to say to space the string into
some symbols differently so he did a 360
yeah so it can be tokenized like this
with warren punctuation x' but we can
decide also to do special things for
4-digit if we want a model that will be
good at processing digit for example or
we can decide to tokenizing in character
like this and also it's the text as some
underlying structure like we can show
you with text structure but
in practice with no networks it's not
very successful nowadays that the
approaches that try to first find the
structure and then exploit this
structure because if you make an error
when detecting the structure of the text
then the rest will fail and actually the
structure is very complex and even
unknown thetac it's not well-defined in
the sense that if you asked several
people what is the structure of a given
desk you might have different answers
not in this simple case but in more
complicated case so yeah in my
presentation in all the approaches I
will treat the text as a flat sequence
of symbols then the neural networks they
take inputs which are text and the
output something and the output will
depends on the application that you want
to do so for example if you want to do
classification the the output would be a
single class or probabilities of our
classes so application our sentiment
analysis and topic classification for
example there is already a sentiment
classifier in the language you give a
text and it just output a class or
probability of classes and the
regression problem is we have also the
sequence of symbols and you want to put
a number so for example sentimental this
is again an application where you may
want to just call the sentence with
respect with probability of being
positive and then there are group of
tasks which are called transduction
where the output is also a sequence so
there are we I distinguish two cases in
one case is where the sequence are the
same length as the input sequence so for
example is the part of speech tagging
where you have a sequence of words and
you want to tag what is the role of the
grammatical role of these words within
the sentence there is also named entity
recognition so you are given a sentence
and you want to detect like this where
are the person where are the cities or
dates and all kinds of entity types
there also language model which I will
illustrate
later when you want to
the probability of a sequence and
usually it's done by predicting the
probability of each symbol even what
what comes before and another
application is to fire question
answering by pointing something in the
text so actually you're given a text
which is a list of symbols you are given
a question for so for example here we
ask where is bond michael jackson and
actually the model is going to give the
position so in terms of characters so
either you can modernize it with words
or character but this models works by
detecting first the stop position and
then the end position so you've got the
same number of input and outputs in the
network and here for example it's
outputting Garry and you can watch the
position of a gariand original string
okay if I ask when is born then it will
focus on another world with another span
okay and there are also a bunch of group
of applications where the output
sequence has a different length than the
input sequence so for example machine
translations translating a language to
another but it can be also more
generally translating natural text to to
a program for example writing a program
from natural text all these kind of
applications you don't know in advance
the the length of your output sequence
also for text summarization you are
given a big text and you want to
summarize it or question answering the
same application like before but by
generating a text like here in front
excellence right we don't always give a
span which comes from the input but
maybe you want to generate the output
okay and conversational modeling also so
a few words about processing text so
there are basically three steps that
download so I already talked about the
tokenization like transforming a string
to a list of symbols then you may want
also to clean the text like to remove
the to remove the stop words or to
to lowercase to do stemming also
stemming is a it's a rule-based
approximation of limitation so it's
about removing removing the plural forms
and infinitive forms of the verbs but
stemming is only rule-based we can
create words that does not exist like
the our ear which come from this
normally limited Asian would be like the
infinitive verb or for this one but
stemming is only based on rules okay and
then once we have the symbols which are
string we have to convert them to and
this is because it will be too
cumbersome to to handle strings in
neural network so first we want to
convert them to NDC's and then later on
to vector so numerical vector and then
its usual neural networks so there are
two ways of so that already two net
encoders to process text in the language
there is one which will output so net
encoder characters which would output
and this is corresponding to some
characters so if I if I put two three
three characters it reads output three
indices and a lot of option well you can
specify your set of characters including
the special characters like start of
string and end of string and the other
useful one is a netting code of tokens
which take which will produce words so
for example if I give it to work two
words like this I will have to end this
is at the end okay and then once we have
this and this is usually we map them to
some vectors which can be learned this
is my next section we call this
embedding it's the process of mapping a
symbol to a vector which is
supposingly a semantically meaningful so
the most basic embedding is called one
not encoding and in the language is
called a unit vector layer so yeah it's
just a layer that will output a vector
with the same size as the
number of tokens it has an endo lexicon
and with one activated like for example
if we put the unit vector on characters
on the world yellow so it will produce
four four four numbers yeah and here
it's only activated at the index which
respond to the letter h-e-l-l-o five
characters and two times l that we see
okay so this representation is not
learned basically and but we can also
which is more typical actually to map
all the indices to a vector of arbitrary
size so this is done with the embedding
layer and it will map so for example if
i do the same with the world ello but I
want the a dimension of 30 whereas
before I was stucked with the number of
characters in my dictionary of
characters so here I have for every row
correspond to a character and I have
such a dimensional vectors which are
random but which can be learned later on
and actually if you if you chain a unit
vector layer with a linear layer is the
same as doing an embedding like I show
here I took the weights learn and put
them in an embedding and I angered twice
the same results here okay so this is
the general principle of embeddings and
they can be applied to to the tokens to
character to sub worlds worlds or our
military worlds and actually actually
they were historically this m bearings
where the first bricks win natural
neural networks from natural language
processing so there were two vacant in
Grove which are which yeah give some
some performance improvement in all the
models so so they will train basically
by a scrapping huge database of text and
you're having some criterion based on
the curriculums of words here for
example they were running representation
that are good at predicting the next
word or the surrounding words or by
tricks factorization techniques on the
cones but matrices of words they come up
with some meaningful representation
semantic vectors for the worlds so here
we see the dictionary so there are air
for four hundred thousand words in this
model and to illustrate how semantic
they are so here it took three lists of
words which are in different categories
animals clothes and fruit and if I if I
plot them using feature space plot then
I see those three groups are well
distinct so it means it encodes the
meaning these vectors encode the meaning
of the words and so they are very good
for example to solve the ambiguity the
synonymy stuff here for example you have
two words that this means the same thing
if you if you have seen them random well
the distance will be close with this and
you your neural networks won't have then
if you feed them with these warr
embeddings to learn which water synonymy
already have it as an input okay and
also there are some interesting
properties for example in this project
you can see that going from the mail
from the mail general like going from
ankle to owned or from King to queen or
- Prince - princess is like it's always
the same translation vectors so not only
the distance are are meaningful in this
space but also the lineal transform
means something and so for example you
can do some arithmetic operation for
example King - man plus woman equal to
Queen this kind of things so there is
the something so here all this model are
in the network repository that that
Carlo already advertised a nice thing
and so you will see by domain with text
you will see that there is a lot of
of these embeddings the globin bearings
yes and another one is this one concept
that this one has the particularity of
working on phrases that is to say your
own group of words so for example here I
plot the nearest a post of living piece
and actually I plot it here yeah and you
see so that there is a cluster array of
what which are rather positive
expressions and then you have a you have
also unto anaemic which are not so not
so far away which means that there is a
component in this vector with which we
like which know that peace and war are
crossed together in teams in terms of
topics and it's also multilingual like
in content somewhat I would not reach
any it can do translation but here I do
some arithmetic Bonjour which means
hello in French - ello + goodbye and we
see our appearing which means the pain
French okay more interestingly because
these foreign bearings they apply a
vector to odd independently of what what
happens around this rod so at three days
of synonymy but they do not serve the
ambiguity of what that can mean several
stuff and depending on the context it
can mean several sir yeah so recently
Allan's Institute released some very
interesting what am bearings which are
now in the in our repository and which
are a two to two main good good point
let's say first there are only based on
character embeddings like yeah they
don't have any it's not based on a
dictionary of words because the problem
is the token and meetings is that if you
got the word that is new that is not in
the dictionary then you can only assign
some arbitrary vector to hit but you are
not going to process it correctly and so
in these embeddings they start from
character and bearings and and so yeah i
will use this representation of neural
networks in my presentation so you know
the sequences have to have to be ready
from
from top to bottom and then it's each
little rectangle here is a vector and
the big boxes are other layers okay and
so what happens in this model is that
you first converts characters when this
is then you you feed the of an embedding
layer that let's assign a small vectors
to each characters and and after you've
got layers of convolutions apply and
then a max pooling on these convolutions
and then it produces one vector for one
world and then this list of weather is
fed fan goes into a recurrent neural
networks that color already introduced
at our we popular to process sequences
and this is the part that cone that
gives to design bearings the fact of
being context dependent because the
output after the recording of the world
will depends on what comes before and
one comes what comes after so this is
the model in our repository so yeah this
was a simplified sketch that I made
because actually there concerning the
convolution this is this pod are running
several coalition's in Tyrell with
several sizes of channel so it's like
looking at 1 1 gram 2 grams 3 grams etc
of characters then they combine in
everything then they have this skip
connection which which is known as the
highway and network architecture then at
this point here that you have an
embedding that is not context dependent
so here each word that was treated
independently and then it's it's fed to
to layer two levels of neural networks
and then it's producing not only one but
three three vectors actually they
release it like this so so this at this
point where we are context independent
we can access this so we have an
amending that is context independent and
then to
to embeddings that are context-dependent
and more or less our level like it's one
layer of B direction 11 n or 2 layer of
be directional arrow name and so if you
give it to two words you will have to
two vectors for each one of this port
which have dimension 1,024 and Allen's
Institute recommend to use by default
the averaging of the of this trembling
so that's what I am doing here I'm just
taking the network adding this sweating
layer which which is computing here the
average of the three ports and then
connecting the three ports whose name I
get using that from information yet to
the spreading layer which is here and
then I have only one part output of size
1024 which I can see it if I give it
okay and now let's illustrate what the
fact that this embeddings are context
dependent so here I give several
sentence with the starting with the word
Apple in different context so sometimes
it means the the fruits sometimes it
means the company sorry there was a
problem with the presentation mode
dating
okay I wasn't here
okay so yeah here it's a feature space
plot so with the embeddings and we see
that we clearly distinguish the three
sentences that are talking about Apple
the company and from the three sentences
which are talking about Apple there's a
fruit
so with these embeddings we are going to
design big wish the world Apple
depending on the context so now I am
going to show with next second part of
text classification how to use this
embedding for a real application so I
took sentiment analysis and as an
application so we have a data set you
know you know repository of data which
is about a movie review so you have
sentences we shall review about movies
and I assign positive or negative level
depending on if there are negative or
and so I tested three models first
random embeddings so I took the glove
one and when you calm the model you can
specify that you want the uninitialized
net so you will only have the same
architecture which is only one layer in
this case but it would be uninitialized
so you have the same same stuff but
weights will be random when you train
with with it and I put it in a classical
architecture I wish I should present by
the way of classification so in
classification yeah you have your
embeddings of words for example and you
can fit it either to a convolutional
neural network is zero straight fit easy
tear or recurrent neural network
something that will combine all the
information in the sentence then you
have to pull it can be done with the max
pooling or in the case of neural
networks you can also decide to take
only the last the last vector also the
back one can be bi-directional or not
and then once you have a vector it's the
classical approach if you need to
classify or which can be only a linear
layer and the softmax layer okay so this
is a
the architecture I did here with my
embedding layer that is going to be
randomly initialized that's why is red
now I feel it to be directional network
some drop out regularized something
earlier aggregation layer of Mac's to do
some global max pulling then a linear
and soft max okay I'm not going to run
the trainings here so to be fast I pre
computed them so this one gives this one
after I do the same exactly the same
experience but I take the real glove not
the uninitialized one so so you see it's
not more red the frosting bearing layer
so it's mean it's in Israel and I've got
this results okay I don't know if you
noticed here I had the 26 validation
error Here I am 21 so I've already
improved and if I took if I take now the
ELMO so so like I said I restrict it
before I take the average of all the
embeddings that Elmo gives as this one
is computationally expensive to to
compute what I recommend to do is to
pre-compute and iron since it should
also recommend this to pre-compute them
on your data set and then to train your
classifier at it on top what isn't open
it as a separate stuff so yeah I won't
run it also here because it's it's
taking some times but I can pre-compute
my training that I'm my validation data
outputs of the ELMO and then the hot I'm
going to put on the on the network is
all the following so the dropout very
near to the pudding and the classifier
with the softmax
and now yeah when I train this the
results are are much better so yes I sum
up everything like this other 3
conversions curl so with this is the
validation error rate we are going
through the training so we see that the
random and meetings
performing wells and Elmo is performing
the best and then we have also the chart
of the three validation rates so we
clearly see that the yeah
using pre-training embeddings helped and
this is the power of transfer learning
so language model some generalities they
are so language model is is about
predicting the sequence of the next word
given the beginning of the sentence and
typically use R for example auto
completion or they are also use to
improve speech to text or image to take
system as it was processing like if your
if your acoustic or optical model just
do some mistakes then maybe knowing the
language you can correct them
it can be used also for that
augmentation like if you are able to
generate text maybe for some tasks you
are going to use a this automatic
generator to have more training data if
you know how to level some data and it
didn't also be used for furn like you
can create sugar walls or stories or
article out of nothing so the
architecture is the following actually
is very similar to classification but we
are just going to classify given the
history so so a classical surface to do
recurrent neural networks then to take
the last yet the last representation to
predict the next one basically so we
have in the net we have we started to
fit the net repository also with some
models so this one was was learn on on
English and yeah I should specific sorry
yes so once you have this network as the
output encoder is netting decoder class
you will be able to call on it all the
property of the net decoder class for
example if you want you can ask for the
top probabilities so here for example I
gave WH as a beginning of the sentence
and I asking for the probability of the
next letter and we can see that there is
I why an i an oh coming first which give
rise to all the why question like what
where why while with who's all this kind
of stuff I can by default if I ask it
will the output mister the most probable
one and then I can ask for random sample
also which time I call it it will give
me a random sample sample from this
distribution this is the distribution
for the character that is estimated and
it was sample from this and then from
this model we can sample as many
character salt as we want next and it
can be done efficiently during net state
object
so next rate object was introduced in
the last version and it's an object that
saw a network and all its intermediate
activation because when we are going to
generate so you are going to generate
here given the begin the next characters
but then you are going to feed the input
and you want the next character but
instead of passing again the full
sequence you don't want to do this so
you want to store the internal state
where you are at at the last point so
this recurrent state basically to to
continue so that's what is done a net
state object so what what we want for
example to do it typically we want to
sample like this and then we if we add
the I it will give the next one then I
add the T that's what we are going to do
with this function here generate random
which create a net state object with the
network and then it's going to nest it
so just to show what is going doing
nested list so if you give it a list
and the start and their length sorry no
no there is no list sorry just start in
the length and I have to put something
great from the lengths yeah so it will
give you the start then what you predict
on the start then it will apply an ST
the function of f so if you do it we are
repeatedly on your sequence then you
will generate all the characters and you
only have to do a string join after to
get the results and so I can generate
random sentence like this which are more
more less funny or if you want to
generate out of nothing I can generate a
point and then it will start a new
sentence for the documentation it can be
used or if I want to start with a given
name I can do this okay I have a part to
show how to train this kind of models
yourself but actually as it is very
similar than what now maybe I can do it
very quickly to introduce the notion
that will be useful after so yeah you
will take a text corpus you will analyze
for example the character that you have
in your corpus define your network and
then to train it we are going to to use
what we call teacher for things but so I
remind that the network has to predict
the next characters and teacher forcing
consisting just ignoring what predicts
the network you just feel with the next
target so for example you have the start
of sequence you have to predict the T
whatever will predict the network you
you copy the T as well do the next input
of the network and then it continued so
this is what we call teacher forcing and
you know framework it can be implemented
with the sequence rest and sequence most
layer so that's what we are going to see
in this picture
so I take my input my input yet I remove
the last character and I give it to my
network that has to predict the the red
the next characters and then if I give
it also to a sequence rest layer it will
remove the first the first frame is for
symbol sorry
and then I I will have this shift like
this and teacher forcing so after I plug
with my loss which is a cross entropy
precision classical for for
classification yes and then I this is a
function also this is practical for text
processing because normally the
databases are huge Here I am showing how
to use the data generator that is to say
instead of passing to net train that I
said that already
all computed I acid a function that
generates my sample sorry for example I
defend a function that will go and get
some some sub strings from a big text
corpus of size between 5 and 30 which is
really arbitrary and there is a bad
choice also like if I if I say 8 it will
output me 8 samples so these are random
drops if we can say so of the of my big
corpus and these are my training samples
like this I should to the network
variable length sequences exoteric
cetera so here again I don't show the
training but it converts and then I have
I have to extract the net and the
prediction part of the net because
everyone that the network was was
wrapped in to another network like this
which was only to have the teacher
forcing thing like this layer us you
don't need it after when you want to use
the network so that's why here I have
net extract and I only extract the
prediction part
okay yeah this one is basically to
reattach the net encoder and I also add
a it's some surgery
I forgot the detail of everything but
the important point is that you are you
want the net encoder and the net decoder
to be back so it's to say here input is
a string it means that I have implicitly
a net encoder of characters or token
attached here and if I extract only this
part and I will lose it so I have to
reattach it after and after yeah I can
predict like I was doing with the with
the previous one okay okay we are not
coming to the last part of this
presentation which presents an important
class of model which are named sequence
to sequence or set to sake and which
take an input sequence and generate an
output sequence without any constraints
any particular constraint on the lengths
the output sequence can be shorter or
longer it's not like with CTC that
presented Khao Lak previously we CTC we
have to produce a shorter sequence and
somehow the alignment between the input
and output sequence has to be modeled to
us but here we don't have this
constraint to seek to second are very
important a third model that can take a
large number of applications so should
such as the machine translation where
you translate a language to another or
text summarization when you want to to
shorten the text and not necessarily
Vinnie Alex also it takes to produce the
summarization of commerce in our
modeling where you were want to produce
an automated boats they're also speech
to text to speech a lot of applications
the first I will present the the
baseline effect to SEC model before
showing an improvement based on
sequester tension so the model was
proposed in 2014 and basically there are
two parts in the model the parts that
encode the input sequence so given input
sequence we are going to produce a fixed
size vector that encode all the
formation of the input sequence in the
second part that will decode so using
this encoded representation of the input
sequence it will feed it to a first
sight of recurrent neural networks and
then we will generate the output
sequence one token at a time so starting
so I dislike on neural network here it
is fed with an embedding of what was
previously generated and as the in the
beginning we have no seen so we feed the
decoder first with a special token to
stay to to tell him okay start the
decoding and then so using this this
representation here of the input
sequence it generates one token so at
the end here is just a classic a
classical classifier that decide which
output tokens to produce then we fit
again this previous token to the decoder
again and again until it produce a
special token to say okay stop decoding
so in terms in the world from language
its own like this so first this is the
chain that encode the input sequence
with just an embedding layer a recurrent
layer and we take the last vector on
this fragment layer to produce a fixed
sized vector of size hundred but
represents the four input sequence then
the decoder as an embedding layer that
takes the pre what was previously
encoded then a recurrent layer and here
we connect the state the first state of
this micron layer to the encoded
sequence vector and then accuracy
classical classifier to produce the next
token as for the language models that
were presented before we are going to
train this using teacher forcing which
means that we feed the input of the
decoder with the real targets and not
what the model predicted so in this part
of the decoder I reminded the de
carreras true inputs the encoded
sequence and what it previously decoded
and here we are just going to fit in
of the decoder with the target using the
special star token and then it will
produce yeah in the same space the
target and a special token to end
generating okay so the teacher the
teacher forcing drinking can be done by
wrapping the decoder and the encoder
into another network which is similar
also the teacher forcing for language
models only difference is here we are
the same color part that feeds the
decoder part but after is the same we
have sequence most and seconds rest
layer to shift to do the shift of the
target and so the decoder each sample
will be the full target to predict the
full into the target are to predict okay
and so I'm going to illustrate it on the
problem of did integral addition but we
string so we we want to pass a string
well we depict an addition of integrals
and we run the results and so it's a toy
problem of of course we can generate as
many examples as you want to study this
problem it's an interesting problem for
translation because it's not a linear
model to noose alignment between the
input and the target like to decide of
this five you have to look at these
three and these two here and then to
produce this eight you have to look at
this five and three and maybe you have
to add one depending on the results that
you asked before so it's an interesting
translation task I will say to perform
integer addition okay so here I
generated some synthetic data set here I
spit into training and validation so I'm
not doing the training I'm not running
the training during this presentation
only showing the results that you can
obtain after one minute of training on
the GPU it's doing less than 1 percent
error so it's working and now I'm going
to show how to use this train network
there there is a little bit of surgery
to do so because if I only
extract the network from the results you
see you you you still have the loss and
yeah everything that was added to do
teacher forcing so this we can remove
this part using net take we take only
the encoder and decoder part then we
take separately the encoder okay it's on
a chain and the decoder which is this
part okay these are the trained ones and
we have to do some surgery on so also on
the decoder to be able to use it so the
first thing is that the difference
between training and decoding is that
when training we were filling the
decoder with the full target to decode
but when we are decoding we are
producing or one took another time so
it's the difference we are going to have
a procedure where we feed the dog the
decoder with one token at a time and if
you use the same net encoder characters
as an input to this decoder the problem
is that you will always output three
tokens when you feel with one character
the input string here and produce the
special tokens okay but it won't fit so
instead we have to change this encoder
for meThe encoder class where each
characters is a class and the empty
string is also a class that will produce
the end of string token okay and so it's
working is producing if I put one
character or zero character it's
producing one token at a time in the
decoder okay and the cylinder tricky
detail is that this state here has to be
removed because we are going to fit it
manually using that state object so okay
so we take the network and we just
remove the state now we can wrap this
decoder into a net state object as
before which has you see one electron
state here that I can programmatically
obtain music net information so you have
the name of this state to be fed
manually then I can write my function to
decode that
take the input sequence produce the
encoded vectors then I rub the decoder
into a net state object but we'll keep
keep trace of the intermediate states a
keep in memory all the internal states i
will initialize it with the encoded
sequence as the first state and then
before I was using nested lists with for
a language model here I use a fixed
point list which does the same but which
will stop when the results does not
change anymore
because actually when we are going to
produce the output token to stop
decoding yeah we did this trick to map
this to the empty string so when the
results does not change it will means to
stop okay and I can make on with this
you see it's working it's performing
digit an addition addition of integrals
by based on strings and I can also
compute the outputs on my full
validation set and compute the accuracy
using classify our measurements so we
have about 90% accuracy so 10% sufferers
so it's different from the error the
error rate we are doing training because
during training here this 1% it's
related to the so the error rate token
by token for each token that you
generate but yeah actually we are each
input each output is a sequence of
tokens and so this accuracy here of
Temple of 90% is that at the level of
the sequence that you generate and it's
the real accuracy that you are
interested in because as soon as you do
one error on one token different even if
your output sequence as 10 tokens per
switch counter as never ok now I come to
a an announcement of this sequence to
sequence model with attention which are
now the state-of-the-art for machine
translation and so our drawback of the
previous approach is that new code
sequence is encoding it to a fixed size
vector and whatever the input
length is and actually it's it will
always be limited like you cannot encode
a huge sequence into a fixed size vector
and the using attention term is to get
rid of this limitation so because we are
going to represent a sequence a sequence
as as an encoded sequence with the
variable lengths are not going to keep
one vector only for the sequence and at
the decoding what happens in attention
is that this intermediate representation
of what we previously decoded is going
to assign weights to all the encoded
vectors of the input sequence so these
attention weights are positive and sum
to one and we use them to compute a
linear combination of the encoded
vectors and it gives a context vector so
it's before we have only one we had only
one context vector for the full decoding
process and what change here is that at
each step of the decoding we are going
to prove one different context vector
which depends on the input sequence and
on what we previously decoded and it
quick to change in each time and then we
concatenate basically this context
vector with the earrin representation of
what we previously generated to produce
the tension layer it's more or less
similar than then the model before but
instead of keeping only one vector here
we keep the full encoded sequence and
there is no tension mechanism in the
middle so at each step of the decoding
every man we we assign weights to all
these encoded vectors which produce one
context vector here and we concatenate
it with the Edin representation of the
decoding and then like before we
generate new token that will be fed into
the decoder unless a special token is
encountered okay in the notebook so I
don't have time to explain all the
details but I should it out how to
generalize and not have a unidirectional
but the directional every n here it's
possible
and the decoding part is very similar
but instead of having only one input so
we're on before we have two parts the
previous what was previously decoded and
context vector now we have also a global
context vector as before but also the
input sequence that will be fed into
attention so attention takes the input
encoded sequence and the output of the
recurrent layer in the decoder okay and
then we concatenate this and fit this
into a classifier for the next token as
before we train it with a teacher
forcing nothing special here okay we
train the model it's a bit longer to
train because and it's a bit better also
I don't know if you remember what the
erase was alph by 2 here and we do some
surgery as before extracting first the
train network without the lost then the
encoder so which has 12 ports the
decoder okay we will change the net
decoder and medic a decoder of the
decoder we also remove this global
internal state here and so now we have
we have a this port to initialize using
that state object also here's a the
decoding function is similar as before
and we can apply it and check that it
works and we can compute the validation
performance and check that it's a bit
better it's a bit better than before
okay it's not a big breakthrough but it
was a toy application but in general
using attention brings a lot of
improvement so it's time to conclude so
to build the applications of natural
language processing your networks are
like three important as we have four
important pieces to achieve the first
the first step is to converse
texts to a list of tokens or treat of
tokens today are presented on the
approaches with list of tokens because
the approach is mysteries are not state
of the art yet and then we convert all
the tokens which are symbols which can
be character sub symbols words or multi
words we convert them to some vectors
which are supposed to be semantically
meaningful in the sense that the
distance in this semantic space is
representative of cementing distance of
two words and then to build the full
network so again I advise to visit first
our model repository for our model Zoo
to see if there are not a network or a
piece of network that can be reused for
your applications we have a bunch of
between the embeddings for example you
don't need to train it yourself you
should rather take a pre train one and
then the layers from sequences are
convolutional layer also recurrent
layers and sequential attention layer
some the main layers of to process
sequences that are interesting for text
and then after once you build your
network of course you have to feed with
your no data that to be relevant and to
optimize any train does a really good
job with optimization methods that are
automatically chosen and are well suited
to to train on sequences and so the
interesting wings are our model zoo
there is also great tutorials on the
wolf on neural network with a special
section on sequence learning and NLP
when you can find many things that I
saved today and also the guide of course
and there is also this blog here which
present another kind of model which is
the question answering one where we we
one given a text and the question point
a certain point the part of take that
and solve the question that so if you're
interested in to knowing how this model
works I encourage you to watch this blog
okay thank you very much yeah these were
clouds for we are done using some water
embeddings of phrases and distances to
the world thank you thank you very much
for this for your attention and now we
will answer some question